all right the sports cards market is
booming but it's not just baseball cards
that are bringing in big bucks here to
tell us more is jimmy garino from game
day sports card sports cards in
henderson we also got steve johnson he's
the toy expert from pawn stars welcome
you guys hey bud thank you okay so i
feel like why are cards so hot right now
so the main thing is
you know everybody that collected the
big boom in the 80s and 90s is you know
they're starting to get into the their
40s and late 30s and they're starting to
have kids and they remember how much fun
it was to collect and buy cards back
then so they're bringing their kids in
involved and they're starting to get
back and ramp everything back up again
it's pretty cool i love it and you
brought in some hot cards what do you
have for us today yeah so we we just
brought in a couple of the cards that we
have at the shop this kaboom here for uh
it's a tom brady kaboom it's out of this
year's uh prestige put it right there so
we can get a shot of it keep it right
there see okay yeah perfect okay
so
it's a kaboom card with tom brady
obviously he's a goat he's a yeah ever
play so anything with his name is
obviously going to be worth a lot worth
a lot of money at that point soccer is
really heavy lately uh hollande he's one
of the best soccer players out there
he's getting ready to transfer into with
the world cup coming up this summer a
lot of people are investing into
the soccer market we have tom brady
again this is his one of his rare rookie
cards is the psa 10 which means it's a
perfect flawless card that we send it
off it gets graded it comes back and
that's how you get the the perfect 10
card what uh steve tell me about this
special card you have back here hold it
up because this one is unbelievable i'm
a chargers fan yeah so this is to my
heart so this is a justin herbert rookie
from national treasures numbered 10 of
10 which is a jersey color match right a
jersey match for him it's got a piece of
the football
which is a relic and the auto this card
right here you're talking 15 to 18
thousand dollars that's worth more than
some cars this card right here yeah and
honestly that's just now in his career
imagine when his career really takes off
okay so uh that's a valuable one uh
let's put it down on the table here
outside of baseball and football i know
garbage pail kids cards are big pokemon
is big what are some other cars that are
big right now non-sports cars have
gotten big so you're talking about
here's some of the original fleer
wrestling look at that that's that's a
gift from me
i knew you would like this this is where
you're going to find the hulk hogan
rookies and how much is something like
that how much is
this worth this box right here is 7 500
whoa so if you have these old school
wrestling cards in your basement in your
attic these cards are worth some money
and then garbage pail kids are huge
right now they're really hot and then of
course pokemon and pokemon is
a massive and i gotta we got to wrap up
here because i do want real quick
because we had these two pokemon cards
earlier these cards that we opened up
earlier are these cards are these cards
worth anything well it looks like you
got a couple of hollows there and one of
them is kind of a full color you're
probably not i'm maybe eight or ten
bucks worth of cards there eight or ten
dollars
gentlemen thank you so much if people
have some cards they want to check out
the value what's real quickly what's the
best way to do it absolutely they could
uh stop by the shop uh we're open from
10 to 6 every single day we're directly
across the street from the raiders
practice facility at 1700 raiders away
and you can hit us on instagram and uh
game day sports cards over thank you
joey appreciate it julian we'll send